I think that climate change issues are
not just long-term goals their
short-term goals because the climate
change problems is includes solutions
also to short-term problems there's a
lot of possibility economically for the
clean tech sector to work on developing
clean tech products which bill which are
necessary and there's a market right
here companies in our sectors they could
benefit on short term by being much more
focused on how to reduce energy costs so
this is a short-term perspective and and
be going into this market from a
short-term perspective they learn the
huge possibilities the huge project
potential on a learned long-term
perspective too so I'm quite sure that
if you really go into this and again
some companies no sense sees that and
what demonstrate benefits of climate
actions and tell that this is not
something that's going to be interesting
in two decades but next year and next
year's again and as soon you really
understand the dynamism of this market
and what can be benefited from this
market I'm sure that we will find out
that these are not issues which we you
couldn't divide in short-term long-term
dimension it's all integrated and you
had to start focusing on it right now
but it's really necessary right now it
is first and foremost that we somebody
and again some companies have posed a
possibility an application to go out and
tell that the true story the right story
that goes from a social economic
financial whatever views that this is
this is a strategy this is a possibility
which is at a hand right now and the
short-term priority should be that to
prevent some of the best in the class
some of the best companies to go out for
their own benefit but for the benefit of
society to to document the possibilities
and therefore be the true business case
the true economic case that this is not
a cost this is not a problem this is a
huge possibility we have right ahead of
us it might be the best possibility the
best opportunity we've had for a long
time and it could be a solutions to some
of the short-term problems like
financial crisis whatever and the
companies who really right now can go
out and demonstrate that will be there
to winners both economically but from
the point of view our branding
attracting talent and so forth so this
could be a short-term priority I'm quite
sure that will really be a win-win
situation for a lot of stakeholders